Qu'est-ce que je dois faire ?
-Je ne sais pas !
-Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
-Je ne sais pas.
Tu veux te voir ?
-Ouais.
Mais tu me fais un tour de magie ou...?
-Je ne sais pas.
-Je peux te faire un tour de magie ?
-Ah, t'en connais un ?!
-Ouais !
-Tu peux me faire un tour ?
-Oui, carrément
-Mais il te faut un jeu de cartes, un truc ?
-Non, non, non, non !
Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec Raphael Callendreau, alias Raphou !
-Ouais.
Bonsoir.
-Il a une éloquence très particulière Raphael.
-Oui, particulière.
Raphael Callendreau et moi, on travaillait, on s'est rencontré du moins grâce à...
-Grâce au RER A.
-Sur le RER A. [rires]
Pour l'association "Rire pour guérir", d'Eric Bouvron.
-Ouais, je fais principalement des choses... artistiques.
-Artistiques, et musicales !
-Musicales, principalement.
-Le "Raphou Show" que vous pouvez voir... il y a 2 ans.
-Ouais, non, plutôt 5 ans.
😱
-Ca fait longtemps qu'on se connaît !
Ah oui tu avais les cheveux longs !
-Ouais, c'est vrai, ouais.
Ouais.
J'avais pas de moustache.
Mais j'en ai toujours pas !
[rires]
J'accompagne Guillaume Darnault au piano sur son solo improvisé.
-Guillaume Darnault ?! Mais c'est pas celui qu'on a vu dans la vidéo de demain ?
-Oui, exactement !
-Hey !
Le monde est petit ! Si ça se trouve je fais les deux vidéos en même temps et je ne le dis pas.
-Mais ça se serait un total...
-Ce serait un truc de fou !
C'est comme si là par exemple on était au Bo-St-Martin, exactement où il joue d'ailleurs.
-Oui, oui, c'est vrai, alors que pourtant c'est une galerie d'art.
Et justement, là on est pas du tout au Bo-St-Martin !
-En temps normal, je devais le mentaliser, je devais lui faire un petit truc en fait à Raphou,
mais, il m'a dit il y a quelques secondes, je vous mettrai le rush,
il m'a dit: "Est-ce que tu veux que je te fasse un tour ?"
Mais évidemment ! Evidemment que je préfère que vous me fassiez des tours !
J'ai 366 vidéos à faire cette année !
Donc si un mec veut bosser à ma place, il n'y a pas de problème.
Je vous mets à la place de mes yeux à moi.
On est tout ouïe Raphael Callendreau !
-Salut ! Alors je regarde ça ? Il est là l'objectif ?
Alors, oui regarde ici.
-Ouais, c'est ça.
Alors bonjour, alors aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre à enlever votre pouce.
Parce que là on croit que le pouce est attaché, mais, moi je peux le détacher.
Enfin, je ne vais pas vous apprendre à le faire, je vais vous montrer...je vais vous le faire,
enfin voilà...
[rires]
Donc attention, là je prends mon pouce.
Hop !
Et là, attention parce que vous voyez... là j'ai pris mon pouce
dans ma main.
Et là...
Ha
Hah
Hah...ha
Hééé
Ha...
Haaah...
Ha
Hoô
Oh...
Ha
Hoa...
HAH !
Ouf...
-C'est incroyable !
-Ca, ça fait flipper les enfants ça. Il ne faut pas le faire aux enfants, ça les fait flippé.
-Tu en connais un autre avec les doigts ?
[rires]
-Ouais...!
Allez ! Regardez, vous voyez les index ?
Je vais passer mon index gauche, vous êtes à l'envers mais pour moi c'est la gauche, je vais passer mon index gauche, à droite.
Juste par un entrechoc de mes mains !
-Moi je dis qu'il y a un montage vidéo !
Si vous voulez suivre Raphael Callendreau, ne vous inquiétez pas, il n'a pas de Facebook, il n'a pas de Twitter, si tu as un site Internet ?
Mais c'est un Myspace, c'est pour te dire si ça date !
[rires]
Donc ne vous inquiétez pas, si vous n'avez pas aimé ce qu'il a fait, il ne le refera jamais.
-J'ai un téléphone à clapet !
[rires]
-L'IPhone zéro !
-J'ai un téléphone à clapet ! [rires]
-Il est 22H ?
-Ouais !
-Et bien, c'est l'heure de vous laisser du coup.
Merci mon Raphou !
-De rien !
💋
-On s'embrasse ?
Je ne t'avais jamais embrassé en 5 ans et tu m'embrasses là ?
-Ouais, parce que aujourd'hui tu piques...
-C'est parce que avant j'avais peur que tu ais une moustache.
On peut te retrouver dans le spectacle de Guillaume.
-Guillaume Darnault et je suis en alternance avec Guillaume Nocture, qui est un autre musicien et humoriste.
Oui, et en fait il accompagne en live cet artiste sur scène qui fait de l'impro. Un One Man Show d'impro très particulier, on va vous en parler demain.
Enfin, "on va"... On est une équipe de 10 personnes Fabien !
Je vais vous en parler demain tout seul. [rires]
Et allez le voir. Je suis allé le voir ce soir, c'était vraiment chouette.
Et du coup, ça habille vraiment le fait que tu passes les CD... que tu fasses... tu sais t'es derrière un piano quoi !
-Ça habille !
-Merci beaucoup ! Pensez à vous abonner à la chaine, on est de plus en plus nombreux et ça c'est ouf !
Abonnez vous, venez me voir en spectacle aussi dans "Fabien Olicard Vous Mentalise !"
Je suis... Non j'étais. Parce l'autre jour j'étais là, du coup... [réfléchi]
Je suis bientôt à Mulhouse. Les prochaines dates de tournée elles sont à Mulhouse à l'Entrepôt Théâtre pour 3 jours.
Venez me voir là-bas comme ça après on fait une vidéo, après, c'est super cool !
Venez aux "Hallucinations Collectives et autres Illusions Fantastiques", je peux vous dire qu'il y a du lourd...! Et cet homme ne sera pas programmé !
Quoi que...
Ca, ça peut être très drôle.
-Haaa !
-Hey ! T'as un truc hallucinant ?!
-Ouais, ouais j'ai un truc...
-On se dit ce n'est pas possible qu'on est vu ça !
[rires]
C'est pas possible qu'on cautionne ça.
On a tout dit ! Alors rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog !
Ciao !